you
and and and
you
all right welcome everybody we are here
on day 8 day 8 of Donald Trump's Senate
impeachment trial today is fortunately
going to be the last day for Donald
Trump's attorneys and I say that because
really they could have gotten up on day
one and simply said hey we don't think
Trump did anything wrong
we don't think he even should be
impeached and we are going to now talk
about unrelated things like Ken Starr
talking about the 1970s Alan Dershowitz
talking about the 1990s and we aren't
really going to address anything other
than with non sequiturs like Trump said
there was no pressure they could I could
have done Trump's defense in five
minutes in five minutes with four
minutes to insult people in the crowd
right I mean so I think it's a good
thing that we're finally getting to the
end of Trump's attorneys I think that it
is good that Jay Sekulow said they don't
plan to take the full 24 hours and we
will soon see exactly how long they
would take saying thank you a sweet wing
for subscribing with twitch prime I
appreciate that so will this go until
8:00 9:00 or 10:00 p.m. we don't know
that again they said they're not going
to take their full time but because
their first day of defense on Saturday
was just two and a half hours they could
go very late today and still not take
their full time then and only then we
will be getting to the debate over
witnesses and at this point I feel like
I've said everything about the witness
situation a hundred times so I will
summarize it just one more time in any
normal trial you would discuss who's
going to testify at the beginning both
sides would then have time to prepare
for those witnesses both sides would
have time to prepare
opening statements that account for the
witnesses that are going to testify
Republicans successfully tabled the
discussion about witnesses until after a
significant portion of this entire thing
is going to be done and now they are
going to say we've already done so many
dozens of hours of stuff I don't know
that we need to keep going and hear for
more people this is going to be their
strategy on fortune
and it may work the the the possible
upside is that Mitt Romney and Susan
Collins so far have said they are
inclined to hear from John Bolton John
Bolton Donald Trump's national security
adviser one that was not indicted some
of Donald Trump's national security
advisors have been indicted this one was
not and we are going to hopefully see at
least four Republicans say we want
Bolton to testify it's not going to
change the outcome of the trial they
will still acquit Donald Trump but
hopefully John Bolton's testimony will
expose the immorality of the foregone
conclusion that is Donald Trump's
acquittal so a lot to look forward to
today I'm going to be here with you
until they get started and a little bit
beyond then I have to step away to some
meetings I will be back throughout the
day and we are expecting some kind of
wrap-up of the case defending Donald
Trump which will make about as much
sense as the defense so far has made
which is very very little very very
little welcome to everybody watching us
on Facebook YouTube and twitch I very
much appreciate it someone wants my
thoughts on Dunkin Donuts because I live
in Massachusetts haven't been to a
Dunkin Donuts in 15 years don't don't
know a thing about it is is is my true
and honest answer let me go to super
chats that are starting to come in on
YouTube Ben Taylor says hey David hope
you were well and your chair is fixed my
actual question is below because it's
too long for a super chat okay Ben I
don't know all I see is super chats
right now so I don't I'm sorry
I don't know with a lot of things
happening here but I I all I see is the
super chat let's see we are going to be
alive we're gonna be live a bunch of
times between now and next week and the
next week my plan I don't actually know
what we will have live when the Iowa
caucuses are happening on Monday night
but I plan to be live hopefully we there
will be sort of results coming in as we
go and then also Tuesday we will be live
for
the state of the union if it is not
postponed due to the Senate impeachment
trial
we just don't know we don't know what's
going on and it's scheduled the State of
the Union scheduled for Tuesday but it
may well get cancelled another super
chat coming in from Alexei Zarya Nova
who says Obama tesseract I have no clue
what that means let me look that up
Obama tesseract oh okay all right it's
just some kind of meme I guess yeah I
don't know too much about any of these
memes but I appreciate the support very
very much I also want to say thanks to
Jackson Casey Jackson Casey is today's
first new member and number 187 Wow 187
using the coupon code impeach 50 thanks
so much I really appreciate your support
new member number 190 will get a free
item I said this yesterday and sadly we
imploded and didn't get their new member
number 190 will get a free item from the
David Pakman show store you can check
out what's available at david pakman.com
slash gear and so we'll have number 188
189 and then 190 free item from the
store they can happen in waves
so I would just hit that sign up button
and sort of close my eyes and hope for
the best as the case may be
thanks to political puppy for the cheer
with the message Trump promised 50
billion to the Palestine people just to
take away attention from this didn't he
try the same stunt summer 2019 as well
and they said no thanks we're gonna have
a full breakdown of that tomorrow
actually we talked about that on today's
bonus show which you get access to as a
member and I will probably break down
that deal on the Wednesday broadcast
show that's at least my plan as of right
now we are about 20 minutes away from
the start of day 8 of Donald Trump's
Senate impeachment trial I know that it
doesn't make sense because yesterday was
day 6 but also Saturday was day 6
it's crazy basically I just go by what
c-span says
Spann yesterday forgot to update and
they called yesterday day six so I
called it day six even though we had day
six already should have been seven and
today is day eight so I'm just going by
the names that uh that c-span assigns
because we don't really have any idea
what's going on we just go by by what
they say oh this is perfect let's listen
to a little bit of gym shorts Georgia
yes yes there too for a couple would do
the best job in playing the policies
that he was elected to implement I think
that's what he's doing during this trial
senators are supposed to sit silently at
their desks but in this chamber returned
courtroom the days are long and the
chairs are hard sketch artist Bill
Hennessy caught a fidgety senators desk
left empty a notepad left behind all
right I don't think we really need that
at this point in time I'd uh I'd rather
talk to you guys for sure okay we will
be okay so a lot of people asking about
phone calls I'm open to doing phone
calls the thing is once this is all done
it's been a pretty damn long day so I'm
not like super inclined to open the
phones you know at 10:30 p.m. Eastern
Time or even later so I'd be open
potentially to opening up the phone
lines maybe like during the dinner break
or something like that yesterday I
proposed it with a membership goal and
we didn't quite get there but maybe I'll
start promoting it earlier I mean maybe
I'll say if we get to 201 new members at
any point today will open up the phone
lines when they go to their to their
dinner break maybe I don't know but if
people would be would be interested in
that yes tesseract is some kind of
mathematical term that that that became
clear once we once we googled that the
Facebook streams are doing a little bit
better each day we've been streaming on
Facebook since the beginning of the
impeachment trial and at one point there
were like 20 people watching on Facebook
and like 4,000 on YouTube it was pretty
pretty lopsided but the Facebook stream
is doing a little bit better and better
if you are watching on Facebook please
do share this there's a million
different impeachment streams and a very
easy and free way to support us is by
sharing watching on Facebook and sharing
which I appreciate
YouTube of course please remember to hit
the like button yesterday we had about a
thousand likes for the stream it's free
hit that like button if you're watching
on YouTube and hit the subscribe button
as well why not
and over on Twitch you can follow us
follow us over on Twitch thanks to
twitch jesh for subscribing with twitch
Prime I appreciate that you are twitch
subscriber 677 per Torah Oh 8 per table
oh oh eight says on twitch trump defense
was so weak and it's not getting better
it is hard to disprove videos of Trump
confessing everything yeah they like to
pretend that everything is complicated
and legally ambiguous and you need legal
scholars to tell you about you know
Andrew Johnson's impeachment to
understand what it's like Trump told
Bolton hold the aid withhold the aid
until we get the smears that's it I mean
that that's that's basically it of
course this is why they don't want John
Bolton to testify
thanks to Cuse 79 for subscribing with
twitch prime you were twitch subscriber
678 very exciting thank you so much for
that maybe we'll even get to maybe we'll
even get to 700 subscribers on twitch
today we we hope that a few Republican
senators will do the right thing and the
problem is if any time over the last
twenty years you've hung your hat on
anything that involves Republican
senators doing the right thing
you've probably ended up disappointed
which is which is why you know I
hesitate to put too much stock in Mitt
Romney and Susan Collins and two others
will do the right thing and force John
Bolton to testify it just seems very
unlikely but we are hearing from a
number of sources in DC that they do
that that that they do have the votes to
get four Republicans to join Democrats
and independents and get John Bolton to
testify Ben Taylor says with a ten
dollar super chat the biggest super chat
of the day at what point is the
Department of Justice military or police
involved in what I mean it was just a
joke that Trump could shoot someone on
the street and get away with it right
this is getting egregious in my opinion
III don't see them getting involved
anytime soon I think they will only get
involved if Donald Trump loses the 2020
election but claims that it was rigged
and that really he won I think in that
case you will see him get involved if
you're watching on Twitch we are in the
middle of a hype train a very early hype
train and we did on the first day of
impeachment complete hype train level
five and since then I think we've gotten
to like level two and not really not not
really beyond there Daniel Krieger
welcome back Daniel great to see both
you and Ben both of you guys have been a
fixtures of the impeachment streams
Daniel Krieger says via super chat
Dershowitz says Bolton's truth is
unimpeachable I did not see that but I
think I don't think John Bolton is a
good guy I don't think John Bolton's
politics are remotely what we need as we
get deeper into the 21st century but I
think under oath if John Bolton
testifies I think he'll tell the truth
period and I I want him to testify and
and certainly hope that he will thank
you to twitch
jesh for cheering 100 bits over on
twitch I appreciate that very much
we will probably so the if you haven't
been following these streams or haven't
seen the start of one the way it usually
goes is right around 1:00 p.m. or a few
minutes past let's see if PBS has a live
shot yet no they're still doing old
coverage right around 1:00 p.m. we will
see a shot of the Senate chamber we will
see people filing in Justice John
Roberts the Chief Justice of the Supreme
Court who presides over the impeachment
will eventually come in there will be a
Christian prayer which we don't
broadcast will we just mute because we
don't think there should be Christian
prayers before these types of hearings
then they will do they will salute the
flag they will do a Pledge of Allegiance
and after all of that we hear from the
sergeant-at-arms who comes up and says
in a very monotone hear ye hear ye hear
ye this is the impeachment of Donald
John Trump then the Chief Justice will
accept
the record of the trial to date into the
record if there are no objections
typically then Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell will talk about the
brakes and dinner time he's already
thinking about dinner time and then we
will hear from Jay Sekulow about the
plan for today how long we expect them
to go who's going to testify that type
of thing so that that's typically how
these go let me say thanks to Joe Brogan
for subscribing with twitch Prime let me
say thanks to G Sneasel for subscribing
with twitch Prime and let me say thanks
to VA G blaster 96 for subscribing with
twitch Prime you guys are twitch
subscribers 679 680 and 681 thank you so
much I very much appreciate that a
princess bunny warrior is asking which
senators should we should be we calling
should we be calling to have maximum
impact and is there something we could
do to put more pressure than just
calling it I I wish I could say yes but
I don't think so I think that we will
probably get a few senators in the
Republican Party to vote for John Bolton
to testify and then after that we will
seat from acquitted I think that that's
the way it's going to happen I wish I
was more optimistic let me say thanks to
Scott Phillips matching today's largest
super chat of the day with the message
isn't it already clear that Republican
senators will acquit regardless of the
facts with or without witnesses new
evidence etc facts are already
irrefutable as it is 100% Scott that's
what I was almost just I finished saying
that right before I read your message
you are 100% spot on there that is
what's going to happen pair tieran is
here with a 100 swedish kronor super
chat now is that is 100 swedish kronor
now more than ten dollars
10:39 okay so that is the largest super
chat of the day pairs 100 swedish kronor
pair says hi all my dear friends yeah
pair has been a big supporter pair has
been
with us on the streams going back to the
ones in the house the house Intel
committee the House Judiciary pair was
actually involved in a pretty funny
Paris Swedish as you can see from his
currency pair was involved in a battle
with a Norwegian viewer they were going
back and forth with successively larger
and larger super chats and ultimately
Sweden actually won out over Norway and
life is good in those in those social
democracies for sure John Smith says via
super chat my David and Friends what do
you call a farmer sowing seeds of
pessimism and doubt a grim reaper folks
very nice it's sort of a pun dad joke of
sorts I guess or something like that I
love it I love it Reuben gazer sends a
to Canadian dollar super chat thanks
Reuben I appreciate that
we are just minutes away presumably from
the start this is video from yesterday
we are still waiting for video to go
live today clearly PBS discussing the
possibility of Susan Collins and Willard
mittens Romney voting for the testimony
of John Bolton let's see what mittens
have the session who are sitting and
impartial justice even one of president
Trump's staunchest allies Senator
Lindsey Graham left the door open
but urged patience I don't know what's
in the manuscript I haven't seen it but
there's need to add to the record and my
view is that we're going to completely
add to the record not selectively
ya know one of their talking points
which is if Bolton testifies we want all
sorts of people to testify even
potentially the Biden's who of course
have nothing to do with what Donald
Trump did er didn't do
Jimmy big nuts is here with a - British
Pound super chat hey Jimmy I was just in
the UK in your presumably in your neck
of the woods had a great time in London
visited Oxford and it was fantastic
Jimmy big nuts says you're doing God's
work here David here's some coins ron
hubbard hey Ron Ron's been around as
well can you interview yang again he
qualified for the debate we've offered
to have Andrew yang back on the program
I've interviewed him two or three times
he's welcome any time he's ignoring us
so he's welcome any time
Daniel Koo says David did you see the
video I edited a view on Twitter no I
did not Daniel and the best way to get
it to me is use the contact form on my
website david pakman.com the via give us
a link to the video it'll come in it'll
be triage and then hopefully I will be
able to take a look at it I always love
to see funny remixes or videos that the
audience makes so by all means send that
in my friend would love to see it ok we
are just three members away from someone
getting a free item from my online store
the black coffee mug by far the most
popular item we do have a coupon code in
Peach 50 the most direct efficient and
honest way of supporting the david
pakman show is to get a membership at
join pakman.com if you do that you can
take 50% just chop it right in half
using the coupon code impeach 50 and
whoever is new member number 190 as you
can see we're at a 187 right now if we
get to whoever's number 190 I will give
you a free item the item of your choice
t-shirt zip up Hoodie coffee mug
whatever from the david pakman show
online store so that will be a really
great thing Rubin gazer says via super
chat toss a coin to your Pakman ovalle
of plenty ovalle of plenty very nice
very
it's a beautiful message on a Tuesday
afternoon or morning if you are on the
west coast absolutely love it I see more
and more folks coming in with questions
about how long today is going to go we
don't know Jay Sekulow said when
Republicans when when Trump's lawyers
started their defense of Trump that they
don't anticipate using nor needing the
full 24 hours and depending on how long
they go today they will use or not use
their full 24 hours I imagine that they
won't because it was a short day on
Saturday if they if they want to get to
their full 24 hours they would have to
go very late into the night so I don't
anticipate that we are going to see that
but maybe something will change maybe
they are panicking now because of even
some Republicans saying we need john
bolton to testify or john bolton should
testify maybe you will see Trump's
lawyers start to go very very long I
don't know tomorrow and Thursday we will
get I believe to questions from senators
of the impeachment managers and Trump's
lawyers although maybe they are first
going to debate witnesses and then later
do the questions it's not completely
clear okay let's see what else we have
going on not too much I think
I think I'm caught up people are telling
me that the the lyrics from Rubin gazer
ovalle of plenty is a song from Witcher
I don't know that yeah that's not a
reference that I know I see everybody
saying it's from Witcher but I've just
I've not seen it so I I sorry I'm sorry
I'm so clueless about what's going on I
admit I didn't even know the Grammys
were on Sunday until I read today that
they were like the worst raided Grammys
and I think it was 12 years or something
like that I'm just I'm just busy with a
lot of different things that's the
reality we uh I said before people
asking about phone calls we've not
opened the phone lines at all during the
impeachment stream so far what I said is
I'm not inclined to do it at the end of
the entire
thing because it's often very late but
if we get to our 201 member goal before
dinner time I mean this is like seven
hours away right six hours away I will
open up the phone lines during their
nearly our dinner break
so something something to think about
she's a lion dog says out-of-left-field
question will de natandy uploading any
new videos on his channel 'not on of
course former TV director and my little
brother NAT on Pakman he has a YouTube
channel called Natanz notes I don't know
if he's going to be doing more videos
he kind of does them when he's available
and he's pretty busy with work so I
don't know what the plan is but maybe he
will I'll ask him next time I talk to
him
gormer Roth says via super chat bernie
has taken a six-point lead in California
Wow yeah bernie is crushing it Bernie
Bernie is rapidly surging in a lot of
different places and we are will
probably do a polling update on the
broadcast show probably tomorrow I guess
maybe Thursday I'm trying to think what
the guest schedule is for upcoming days
maybe tomorrow we'll do it
Zachary Monroe hey Zach Zach's been here
on almost every livestream so far
Zach says via super chat I love the show
David I've been watching your show for
the past few months since whistleblower
complaint keep up the work good work
thank you so much Zachary and yeah we've
had a big influx of people where are we
right now in terms of subscribers we're
at 797 600 we had this goal of getting
to 800,000 subscribers my my birthday
which is Sunday I don't know if we're
gonna do it it's tight like we'll have a
day where we gain a thousand subscribers
in a day and I'm thinking it's gonna
happen and then a couple days will go by
where we gain like a hundred or fifty
and then it's not so clear it'll
probably be a photo finish it'll
probably be a photo finish
ron Hubbard says have you offered Pete
amy-jo or Bernie to be on your show yes
producer Pat contacted every candidate
and they have not expressed interest I
don't know that we're big enough I don't
know that we're big enough I think
that's the reality
I don't we've had yang on Andrew yang
early and once he became more well-known
he started ignoring us so it's it's a
shame I also I interviewed marianne
williamson years ago but that was before
she was a candidate for anything let me
say thank you to Kendall Dillard who is
new member number 188 and let me say
thank you to jonathan Bergstein who is
new member number 189 the next person to
sign up at join pakman.com gets a free
item from my store I said that new
member number 190 I will personally
handle sending you whether you want a
coffee mug or the evanka t-shirt or the
Trump's Big Brain t-shirt or just the
David Pakman show logo t-shirt the next
person will be new member number 190 and
you'll get a free item and you can also
take the coupon code impeach 50 saves
you 50% off of the membership of your
choice yes there's people in the chat I
see who got the black mugs people love
those black coffee mugs it's like an
oversized mug it's larger than a normal
mug and it just looks great it's a great
shiny it's heavy it's uh it's it's it's
a fantastic product ron Hubbard says
Tulsi and Mary Ann declined to come on
wow shake my head yes yes they did we
invited Tulsi on the show and she didn't
I don't even think we heard back from
them quite frankly and my friends very
very sad we are now waiting for c-span
expecting them to go live any second PBS
still running reruns of yesterday's
coverage and the c-span feed has not
gone live yet so I think we can safely
say they have not yet started but
expecting sometime in the next five
minutes the last day today the last day
of Donald Trump's lawyers presenting we
heard last night from Alan Dershowitz
making just a vague constitutional
argument we heard from Kenneth Starr
yesterday talking to us about the 1970s
and the 19th century even Andrew Johnson
and all sorts of unrelated things let's
see political puppy says deep he reads
questions on twitch when you ask with
bits when he sees them
when people ask when subscribing to
twitch Prime or if they have the points
for highlighted questions the odds are
pretty good as there are fewer viewers
here compared to YouTube but there he
sees them more clearly I think very good
assessment very very good assessment of
of how the entire thing is working I
love it you're absolutely right
[Laughter]
okay let me say thank you to new member
number 190 getting a free item from the
David Pakman show store member number
190 is Misha Owens Misha
Owens congratulations Misha please
contact me via my website say I was
member number 190 tell me the item you
want if it's a t-shirt make sure to tell
me the size and the color if it's one of
the mugs let me know if it's the white
one with the black mug and your dress we
will ship it anywhere in the world also
I want to say thanks to Cameron
Mccorquodale I think I pronounced
Mccorquodale Mccorquodale Cameron
Mccorquodale is new member number 191
Tiffany Patti is new member number 192
and Draya Sanchez is new member number
193 thank you very much I appreciate
that support and it's it's great to see
so many new members as we are just
moments here just moments from the start
of day 8 of the Senate impeachment trial
judy Woodruff seems to be back live it
seems like they are getting ready for
kicking this off any second expecting it
to go live
maestro mouse says please make sure we
have a mod in twitch chat today the
start of yesterday's stream had a few
people abusing the lack of mods I
believe we have mods yeah I think we
have moderators on both YouTube and
twitch today
let's see who's coming in we have of
course the chaplain who is going to be
giving a prayer which we will be muting
who else do we see here Daniel Goldman
we saw here democratic council but looks
like he's standing over on the
Republican side
we see Adam Schiff we see Hakeem
Jeffries who else is working their way
in here Zoe Lofgren we don't know if
Jerry Nadler will be back today very sad
situation with Jerry Nadler his wife is
undergoing treatment for pancreatic
cancer he missed yesterday because he
had to be in New York with her
completely understandable and we wish
her the best we wish him the best and
would love to see him back when he is
ready and able and available at his desk
in his chair and his leadership position
getting ready for the proceedings okay
they're about to start but horrible
horrible situation with Jerry Nadler
family John good friend says via super
chat David do you think that useless
chair of the Senate Intelligence
Committee Richard Burr might do the
right thing and vote to convict no I
mean III I'm glad to elaborate but the
answer is no I don't believe that that
is going to happen let me say thank you
and welcome to Kody Harper Kody is new
member number 194 194 using the
impeached fifty coupon code as I said if
we get to 201
today and we're only seven away I will
open up the phone lines and take phone
calls the entire dinner break which is
like five to six hours away and we will
we will adjudicate that a little bit a
little bit later we should be just
moments away from the beginning of day
eight of Donald Trump's impeachment
trial day three of three for Donald
Trump's attorneys we see his attorneys
coming in we see Jay Sekulow
over here we see this maybe Pam Bondi
who presented yesterday hilariously it
was like a comedy show when she
presented I mentioned already Adam
Schiff is here this is norm Eisen who
you might remember from the house
hearings who else do we have at the
ready that's mostly everybody I
recognized right now although other
people continuing to file in and of
course waiting for
Chief Justice - to make it in do you
think Trump will be unfortunately
acquitted says Tai Jager on twitch
yes I believe Donald Trump will be
acquitted that is absolutely accurate
let's see there is Chief Justice John
Roberts Karen what is he carrying in I
wasn't interesting did anybody see that
he was carrying like a big black box in
there's a court of impeachment the
chaplain will lead us in prayer okay and
we mute the prayer we don't do the
prayer we I just don't think there
should be a prayer and yeah we have been
silencing the prayers we just don't need
it folks we just don't need it let's see
other comments coming in honestly this
whole thing is a joke Bolton's assistant
already said that the Ukrainian issue in
his book is false so why do they need
Bolton to be a witness if his book isn't
true yeah I believe Bolton / Bolton's
assistant at this point I want to get
Bolton under oath do you think there's a
possibility that they call John Bolton
to testify yes see Burtis maximalists i
do believe so and i've said i've said
why i believe that to be the case i i
think we are there's a good chance that
we see Bolton testify whether it'll be
in public or behind closed doors is a
different question for sure
the Christian prayer is taking place
after it's done there will be a saluting
of the flag then there will be the
sergeant-at-arms invoking silence on
penalty of imprisonment during the
impeachment trial then and only then
will we hear from Mitch McConnell what
the plan is for today yeah people are
confused about the religion in politics
why are they doing a Christian prayer I
don't know but we're not taking the bait
we're not participating it participating
in it rather I will say the maybe I will
stand for the saluting of the flag will
say no I'm kidding so I think now they
do the Pledge of Allegiance there's
something weird going on with the c-span
feed it's kind of like skipping in a
very strange way that is happening with
c-span that's not us I don't know why
that's going on
it's really really odd but there's not
too much I can do about it all right
let's listen now to the sergeant-at-arms
please be seated
if there is no objection the journal of
proceedings of the trial are approved to
date without objection so ordered
the sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation yes
hear ye hear ye hear ye commanded to
keep silent on pain of imprisonment
while the Senate of the United States is
sitting for the trial of the articles of
impeachment exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States as
chief justice the majority leader is
recognized we expect several hours
obsession today with probably one quick
break in the middle oh ok so they
apparently will not be going to dinner
today thank you
pursuant to the provisions of Senate
resolution 483 the counsel for the
president have 15 hours and 33 minutes
remaining to make the presentation of
their case though will not be possible
to use the remainder of that time before
the end of the day the Senate will now
hear you mm-hmm
let's see how they big picture for us
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
just to give you a very quick brief
overview of today we do not intend to
use much of that time today mr. chief
justice we intend to be our goal is to
be finished by dinnertime and well
before we'll have three presentations
first film and deputy White House
Counsel veinte c-span would you like
presentation we'll take a break if
that's okay with you mr. leader and then
after that I'll finish with a
presentation so that's our goal for the
day and with that I'll turn it over to
Pat Philbin all right
mr. Chief Justice members of the Senate
Majority Leader McConnell Minority
Leader Schumer I'd like to start today
by making a couple of observations
related to the abuse of power charge in
the first article of impeachment and I
wouldn't presume to elaborate on
professor Dershowitz his presentation
from yesterday yesterday evening which I
thought would be a complete and
compelling but I wanted to just add a
couple of very specific points in
support of the exposition of the
Constitution and the impeachment Clause
that he set out and it begins from a
focus on point in the debate about the
impeachment clause at the Constitutional
Convention where maladministration
was offered by George Mason as a grounds
for impeachment and James Madison
responded that that was a bad idea and
he said so Vega term will be equivalent
to a tenure during the pleasure of the
Senate and that a deep-seated concern
that Madison had and it's part of the
whole design of our Constitution for
ways that can lead to exercises of
arbitrary power the Constitution was
designed to put limits and checks on all
forms of government power obviously one
of the great mechanisms for that is the
separation of powers powers the
structural separation of powers in our
Constitution but it also comes from
defining and limiting powers and
responsibilities and a concern that
vague terms vague standards are
themselves an opportunity for the
expansion of power and the exercise of
arbitrary power and we see that
throughout the Constitution and in the
impeachment Clause as well and this is
governor Morris argued in discussing the
impeachment clause that only few
offenses he said few offenses ought to
be impeachable and the case is ought to
be enumerated and defined and that's why
we see in the debates that the constant
tution there was a many terms had been
included in earlier drafts included in
earlier drafts when it was narrowed down
to treason and bribery and there was a
suggestion to include maladministration
which had been a ground for impeachment
in English practice the framers rejected
it because it was too vague it was too
expansive it would allow for arbitrary
exercises of power and we see throughout
the Constitution in terms that row 11
Clause the same concern one is in the
definition of treason the framers were
very concerned that the English practice
of having a vague concept of treason
that was malleable and could be changed
even after the facts to define new
concepts of treason was dangerous it was
one of the things that they wanted to
reject from the ink from the English
system so they defined in the
Constitution very specifically what
constituted treason and how it had to be
proved and then that term was
incorporated into the impeachment clause
similarly in the rejection of
maladministration which had been an
impeachable offense in england the
framers rejected that because it was
vague a vague standard something that's
too changeable that can be it can be
redefined can be malleable after the
fact allows for the arbitrary exercise
of power and that would be dangerous to
give that power to the legislature as a
power to impeach the executive and
similarly and it relates again to the
impeachment clause the greatest dangers
from having changeable standards that
existed in the English system was bills
of attainder under a bill of attainder
the parliament could pass a specific law
saying that a specific person had done
something unlawful they were being
attainted even though it wasn't unlawful
before that and the framers rejected
that entire concept in article 1 section
9 they eliminated both section 9 they
eliminated both bills of attainder and
all ex post facto laws for criminal
penalties at the federal level and they
also included a
to prohibit States from using bills of
attainder now in the English system
there was a relationship to some extent
between impeachment and bills of
attainder because both to get at
officials in the government you could
impeach them for an established offence
or you could pass of a bill of attainder
and it was because the definition of
impeachment was being narrowed the
George Mason at the debate suggested he
pointed out in the English system
there's a bill of attainder it's been a
great useful tool for the government but
we're eliminating that eliminating that
and now we're getting a narrow
definition of impeachment we ought to
expand it to include maladministration
and Madison said no one the framers
agreed we have to have enumerated and
defined offenses not a vague concept not
something that can be blurry and
interpreted after the fact and it could
used essentially to make policy
differences or other differences like
that the subject of impeachment all the
steps that the framers took in the way
they approached the impeachment clause
were in terms of narrowing restricting
constraining and numerating offenses and
not a vague and malleable approach anger
system and I think the minority views of
Republican members of the House
Judiciary Committee at the time of the
Nixon impeachment inquiry summed this up
and reflected it well because they
explained and I'm quoting from the
minority views in the report the whole
tenor of the framers discuss the whole
purpose of their many careful departures
from English impeachment practice was in
the direction of limits and of standards
an impeachment power exercised without
extrinsic and objective standards would
be tantamount to the use of bills of
attainder and ex post facto laws which
are expressly forbidden by the
Constitution and are contrary to the
American spirit of Justice
and what we see in the house managers
charges and their definition of abuse of
power is exactly antithetical to the
framers approach because their very
premise for their abuse of power charge
is that it is entirely based on
subjective motive not objective
standards not pre to be defined offenses
but the president can do something that
is perfectly lawful perfectly within his
authority but if the real reason as
professor Dershowitz pointed out that's
the language from their report the
reason in the president's mind is
something that a fair it out and decide
is wrong
that becomes impeachable and that's
exactly malleable and it's something
that I think a telling factor that
reflects how malleable it is and how
dangerous it is is in the House
Judiciary Committee's report because
after they define their concept of abuse
of power and they say that it involves
you're exercising government power for
personal government power for personal
interest and not the national interest
and it depends on your subjective
motives they realize that that's
infinitely malleable there's not really
a clear standard there and it's
violating a fundamental premise of the
American system of justice that you have
to have notice of what is wrong you have
to have notice of an offense and this is
something that professor Dershowitz
Woods pointed out last night there has
to be a defined offense in advance and
the way they try to resolve this is to
say well in addition to our definition
high crimes and misdemeanors involve
conduct that is recognizably wrong to a
reasonable person and that's their kind
of add have an unconstitutionally vague
standard they don't have a standard that
really defines a specific offense they
don't have a standard that really
defines in coherence terms that are
going to be identifiable what the
offenses are so they just add on and
it's got to be recognizably wrong and
they say that they're doing this
to resolve attention they call it within
the Constitution because they point out
and this is quoting from the report the
structure of the Constitution including
its prohibition on bills of attainder
and the ex post facto clause implies
that impeachable offenses should not
come as a surprise that's exactly what
professor Dershowitz pointed out and
everything about the terms of the
Constitution Dushan speaking of an
offense and a conviction that it's a
crime should be tried by jury except
impeachments they all talk about
impeachment in those criminal offense
terms but the tension here isn't within
the Constitution it's between the house
managers definition which lacks any
coherent definition of an offense that
would catch people by surprise and the
Constitution that's the tension that
they're trying to resolve is between
their malleable standard that actually
states no clear offense and the
Constitution and the principles of
Justice embodied in the Constitution
that requires some clear offense so he
wanted to point that out in relay to the
standards for impeachable offenses
because it's another piece of the
constitutional puzzle that fits in with
the exposition that professor Dershowitz
set out and it also shows an inherent
flaw in the house managers theory of
abuse of power regardless of whether or
not one accepts the view that an
impeachable offense has to be a crime it
defined crime find crime there is still
the flaw in their definition of abuse of
power that it is so malleable based on
purely subjective standards that it does
not provide any cognizable notice of an
offense it is so malleable it in effect
recreates the offense of
maladministration at the mers expressly
rejected as professor Dershowitz
explained
the second point that I wanted to make
is that how do we tell under the house
managers standard what an illicit motive
is when there's an illicit motive how
are we supposed to get the proof of
what's inside the President's head
because of course motive is inherently
difficult to prove where you're talking
about as they've conceded they're
talking about perfectly lawful actions
on their face within the constitutional
authority of the president but they want
to make it in P chable if it's just the
wrong idea inside the president's head
and they explain in the House Judiciary
Committee report that the way will tell
if the president had the wrong motive is
we'll compare what he did to what
staffers in the executive branch said he
ought to do so they say quote that the
president quote disregarded United
States foreign policy towards Ukraine
end quote and that he ignored quote
unquote official policy that he had been
briefed on and that he quote ignored
defied and confounded every agency
within the executive branch end quote
that is not a constitutionally coherent
statement the president cannot defy
agencies within these article 2 section
1 of the Constitution vests all of the
executive power in a President of the
United States he alone is an entire
branch of government
he sets policy for the executive branch
he's given vast power and of course
within limits set by laws passed by
Congress and within limits set by
spending priorities priorities spending
laws passed by Congress he within those
constraints sets the policies of the
government and in areas of Foreign
Affairs military affairs national
security which is what we're dealing
with in this
KACE Foreign Affairs head of state
communications he has back he has vast
powers as professor Dershowitz explained
for over two centuries the president has
been guarded as the sole organ of the
nation in foreign affairs so the idea
that we're going to find out when the
president had the wrong subjective
motives by comparing what he did to the
recommendations of some interagency
confers is fundamentally
anti-constitutional it inverts the
constitutional structure and it's also
fundamentally anti-democratic because
our system is rather unique in the
amount of power that it gives to the
president the executive here is more
much more power than the parliamentary
system but part of the reason that the
president can have that power is that
he's directly democratically accountable
to the people there is an election every
four years to ensure that the president
stays democratically accountable to the
people but those staffers in these
supposed interagency who have their
meetings and make recommendations to the
president are not accountable and are
not accountable to the people there is
no democratic legitimacy or
accountability to their decisions or
recommendations and that is why it is
the president as head of the executive
branch who has the authority to actually
set policies and make determinations
regardless of what the staffers may
recommend they're there to provide
information and recommend recommend a
shion's not to set policy so the idea
that we're going to start impeaching
presidents by deciding that they have
elicit motives if we can show that they
disagree with some interagency consensus
it's fundamentally contrary to the
Constitution and fundamentally
anti-democratic so those were the two
observations I wanted to add to
supplement specifics on professor
Dershowitz his comments from last night
now I want to shift gears and respond to
a couple of points that the house
managers have brought up that are really
in completely extraneous
to this proceeding they involve matters
that are not charged in the articles of
impeachment they do not direct really
direct really direct really excuse me
relate directly to the president for his
actions but they are accusations that
were brought up it's somewhat recklessly
in any event and we cannot close without
some response to them
and the first has to do with the idea
that somehow the White House and and
White House lawyers were involved in
coverup related to the transcript of the
July 25th call because it was stored on
a highly classified system so let me
start with that the house managers made
this accusation there was something
nefarious going on but let's see what
the witnesses actually had to say
Lieutenant Colonel lieutenant count
colonel Alexander VIN Minh and remember
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh is the
person who was listening in on a call
and who raised a concern the only person
who went and raised a concern with NSC
lawyers that he thought he thought there
was something improper something wrong
with the call even though he later
conceded under cross-examination it was
really a policy concern but and he had
to say that he did not think he said so
I do not think there was malicious
intent or anything of that nature to
cover anything up he's the one who went
talked to the lawyers he's the one whose
complaint spurred the idea that wait
there might be something that's really
sensitive here we should make sure that
this is not going to leak he thought
there was nothing covering it up his
boss senior director Tim Morrison had
similar testimony so the best year
knowledge there's no malicious intent in
moving the transcript to the compartment
and server correct and the idea that
there was some sort of cover-up is
further destroyed by the simple fact
that everyone who is part of their jobs
needed access to that transcript
still had access to it including
lieutenant-colonel VIN Minh right so the
person who raises a complaint still has
access to the transcript the entire time
and this is the way the mone explained
that and even on the code word server
you had access to it yes so at no point
in time during the course your official
duties were you where you denied access
to this information correct correct and
to your knowledge anybody on the NSC
staff that needed access to the
transcript for their official duties
always was able to access it correct
people that had a need to know and I
need to access it once it was moved to
the compartment system yes okay now as
mr. Morrison testified he'd recommended
restricting access to the transcript not
because he had any concern that there
was anything improper or illegal but he
was concerned about a potential leak and
as he put it how that quote would play
out in Washington's polarized
environment end quote and would quote
affect the bipartisan support of our
Ukrainian partners currently experienced
in Congress and he was right to be
concerned potentially about leaks
because the Trump administration has
fast faced national security leaks at an
alarming rate
Lieutenant Colonel VIN Minh himself said
that concerns about leaks seemed
justified and it was not unusual that
something would be put in a more restore
restricted circulation now what else is
in the record evidence Mr Morrison
explained his understanding how the
transcript ended up on that server I
spoke with the NSC executive Secretariat
staff asked them why and they did their
research and they inform me it had been
moved to the higher classification
system at the direction of John
Eisenberg whom I then asked why I mean
that's that was the judgment he made
that's not necessarily mind a question
but I didn't understand it in each
content retold me I gave no such
direction
he did his own inquiry and he
represented back to me that it was his
understanding was it was a kind of
administrative error that when he also
gave direction to restrict access the
executive Secretariat staff understood
that as a apprehended there was
something in the content of the men con
that could not exist on the lower
classification system so the best your
knowledge there's no malicious intent in
moving the transcript to the compartment
and server correct everyone who knew
something about it and who testified
agreed there was no malicious intent the
call was still available part of their
job and it certainly wasn't covered up
for deep sixed in some way the president
Declassified it and made it public so
why were even here talking about these
accusations about a cover-up
when it's a transcript that was
preserved and made public is somewhat
absurd now the other point I'd like I'd
like to turn to another accusation from
the house managers is that the
whistleblower complaint when the
whistleblower complaint was not
forwarded to Congress they've said that
lawyers at the Department of Justice
this time they accused OLC the office of
legal counsel of providing a bogus
opinion for why the director of national
advanced the whistleblowers complained
to Congress and manager Jeffrey said
that OLC opined quote without any
reasonable basis that the Acting DNI did
not have to turn over the complaint to
Congress end quote and the way he
portrayed this now there's a statute
that says if the Inspector General of
the intelligence community finds a
matter of urgent concern it must me it
must be forwarded to Congress and
manager Jeffrey's portrayed this as if
the only thing to decide was were these
claims urgent he said quote what could
be more urgent than a sitting
president's trying to cheat in an
American election
by soliciting foreign interference
that's not the only question the statute
doesn't just say if it's urgent
you have to forward it it talks about
urgent concern as a defined term now if
the house managers want to come
accusations that the political and
career officials at the office of legal
counsel which we all know is a very
respected office of the Department of
Justice provides opinions for the
executive branch on what governing law
is they should come backed up with
analysis so let's look at what the law
actually says and I think we have the
slide of that heard that urgent concern
is defined as a serious or flagrant
problem abuse violation of law relating
to the funding administration or
operation of an intelligence activity
within the responsibilities and
authority of the Director of National
Intelligence fide information so the
office of legal counsel was consulted by
the general counsel at the DA's office
and they looked at this definition and
they did an analysis and they determined
that the alleged misconduct is not an
urgent concern within the meaning of the
statute because they're not just talking
about do we think it's urgent do we
think it's important know they're
analyzing the law and they looked at the
terms of the statute the alleged
misconduct is not an urgent concern
within the meaning of the statute
because it does not concern the funding
administration or operation of an
intelligence activity under the
authority of the DNI remember what we're
talking about here is a head of state
communication between the President of
the United States and another head of
state this isn't some CIA operation
overseas this isn't the NSA doing
something this isn't any intelligence
activity going
within the intelligence community under
the supervision of the DNI it's the head
of the executive branch head of the
executive branch exercising his
constitutional authority engaging in
foreign relations with a foreign head of
state
so in reaching that conclusion the
office of legal counsel looked at the
statute case law the legislative history
and it concluded that this phrase origin
concern includes matters relating to it
intelligence activities subject to the
DNI supervision but it does not include
allegations of wrongdoing arising
outside of any intelligence activity or
outside the intelligence community
itself and that makes sense this statute
was born ability of the Inspector
General of the intelligence community
overseeing the activities of the
intelligence community to receive
reports about what was going on at
intelligence agencies those that are
members of the intelligence community if
there was fraud waste abuse something
unlawful in those activities it was not
meant to create and inspect an Inspector
General of the presidency an inspector
general of the Oval Office to purport to
determine whether the president in
exercising his constitutional
authorities had done something that
should be reported this law is narrow
and it does not cover every alleged
violation of law will see for other
abuse that comes to the attention of a
member of the intelligence community
just because you're in the intelligence
community happen to see something else
doesn't make this law apply and the law
does not make the inspector general for
the intelligence community responsible
for investigating and reporting on
allegations that do not involve
intelligent activities or the
intelligence community
now nonetheless the president of course
released the July 25th call transcript
and it was also not the end of the
matter that the whistleblower complaint
and the DNA the I CI G's letter were not
sent directly to Congress because I will
see explained that if the complaint is
not not involve an urgent concern but if
there's anything else there that you
want to have checked out the appropriate
action is to refer the matter to the
Department of Justice and that's what
the dnase office did they sent the IC
IGS letter with the complaint to the
Department of Justice and that of
Justice looked at it and this was all
made public some time ago the Department
of Justice examined the exact
allegations of the whistleblower and the
exact framing and concern raised by the
Inspector General which had to do with a
potential of perhaps a campaign finance
law violation DOJ looked at it looked at
the statute the statutes analyzed it and
determined there wasn't a violation and
it closed the matter and it announced
that months ago all right when something
gets sent over to the Department of
Justice to examine you can't call that a
cover-up everything here was done
correctly the lawyers analyzed the law
the complaint was sent to the
appropriate person for review it was not
within the statute that required
transmission to Congress and everything
was handled entirely properly so again
actually extraneous to the matters
before you there's nothing about this
these two points in the articles of
impeachment but it merits a response
when reckless allegations are made
against those at the White House and at
the Department of Justice and with that
mr. chief justice all yield back my time
to mr. Sekulow
[Music]
Thank You mr. chief justice Majority
Leader McConnell Democratic leader
Schumer house managers members of the
Senate what we are involved in here
as we conclude is perhaps the most
solemn of duties under our
constitutional framework the trial of
the leader of the free world and the
duly elected president of the United
States it is not a game of leaks and
unsourced manuscripts that's politics
unfortunately and Hamilton put
impeachment in the hands of this body
the Senate precisely and specifically to
that prey this is the greatest
deliberative body on earth in our
presentation so far you've now heard
from legal scholars from a variety of
schools of thought from a variety of
political backgrounds but they do have a
common theme common theme with the dire
warning danger danger danger to lower
the bar of impeachment of impeachment
would impact the functioning of our
constitutional republic and the
framework of that constitution for
generations I asked you to put yourself
and reporting Mr ships manager shifts
statement of spa be about putting
yourselves in the shoes of someone else
and I I said I'd like you to put your
shoes yourself in the shoes of the
president and I think it's important as
we conclude today that we reminded of
that fact the President of the United
States in the United States before he
was the president was under an
investigation it was called crossfire
hurricane it was an investigation led by
the FBI the Federal Bureau of
Investigation James Comey eventually
told the president a little bit about
the investigation and referenced the
steel dossier James Comey the DA then
director of the FBI said it was
salacious and unverified so salacious
and unverified that they used it as a
basis to obtain basis to obtain FISA
warrants members managers here managers
at this table right here said that any
discussions on the abuse from the
Foreign Intelligence Surveillance Act
utilized to get the FISA warrants from
the court or conspiracy theories I told
you at the very beginning I asked do you
put yourselves in the shoes of not just
this president of any president that
would have been under this type of
attack
five people affiliated with his campaign
American citizens affiliated the people
of hippocampus campaign citizens of the
United States being surveilled pursuant
to an order that is now been
acknowledged by the very court that
issued the order that it was based on a
fraudulent plinth presentation in fact
evidence specifically changed changed by
the very FBI lawyer who was in charge of
this change to such an extent that the
foreign surveillant that the foreign
surveillance intelligence court as I
said earlier I'm not gonna repeat it
again issued two orders saying that when
this agent this lawyer made these
misrepresentations to the National
Security Division they also made a
misrepresentation to a federal court the
federal court the foreign survey a court
where there are no defense witnesses a
court where there are is no
cross-examination it's a court based on
trust that trust was violated and then
the director of the Federal Bureau of
Investigations Bureau of Investigation
James Comey
decides he will leak a memo a big
conversation he had with the President
of the United States and he is leaking
the memo for a purpose he said to obtain
the appointment of a special counsel and
lo and behold a special counsel was
appointed and it just so happens that
that FBI agent lawyer
who committed the fraud on the FISA
Court became a lawyer from the Muller
investigation only to be removed he
removed because of political animus and
bias found by the Inspector General then
we have a Special Counsel investigation
Lisa page agent Sturrock I'm not gonna
go into the details you know them
they're never see their uncontroverted
the facts are clear but does it bother
your sense of justice even a little bit
even a little bit that Bob Muller
allowed the evidence on the phones of
those agent to be wiped clean while
there was an investigation going on by
the inspector general now if you did it
if you did it
managership if you didn't manager
Jeffries if I did that destroyed
evidence if anyone in this chamber did
this we'd be in serious trouble they're
serious trouble as they get they're
serious trouble as they get fired
Bob Muller's explanation for it is I
don't know what happened I don't know
what happened I can't recall the
conversations you can't view this case
in a vacuum you are being asked and I
say this with the utmost respect you are
being asked to remove an elected duly
elected president of the United States
this isn't some we had references to law
school exams I love that fact I thought
that was a great analysis yesterday and
that but I want to focus today or my
section on what you're being asked to do
you are being asked to remove a duly
elected president
the United States and you're being asked
to do it in an election year in an
election year there are some of you in
this chamber right now that would rather
be someplace else
and that's why we'll be brief I
understand you'd rather be someplace
else why would you rather be someplace
else because you're running for
president the nomination of your party I
get it but this is a serious
deliberative situation you're being
asked to remove Abdulelah you're being
asked to remove a duly elected president
the United States that's what the
articles of impeachment call for removal
so we had a special counsel and we got
the report and just for a moment to any
president that would be under this
situation you're number four at the
Department of Justice his wife is
working for the firm that's doing the
opposition research on him and is
communicating with the foreign former
spy
Christopher Steele to put together the
dossier and it's being handled by
Christopher Steele through Nelly or two
or her husband then the fourth ranking
member at the Department of Justice
Bruce or and all of this is going on and
he doesn't want to tell and he's
testified to this he doesn't want to
tell everybody what he's doing because
he's afraid he might have to stop might
have to stop
how did this happen how did this happen
this is the Federal Bureau of
Investigation and then we ask why is the
president concerned about advice he's
being given put yourself in his shoes
put yourself in his shoes keep giving
you and our approach has been to give an
overview and to be very specific to
remove a duly elected president which is
what you're being asked to do for in
essentially policy disagreements to her
a lot about policy although the one that
still it still troubles me and I'm like
this idea that the president
it was simply several demanders only
doing these things for himself
understanding what is going on in the
world today as we're here they raised it
by the way I'm not I'm not trying to be
disrespectful I'm they raised him this
president is only doing things for
himself while the leaders seem parties
by the way at the highest level to
obtain peace in the Middle East to say
you're only doing that for yourself I
think the irony of that that those
statements were made while all of that
was going on and and other acts that
this bodies past some of the bipartisan
to help the American people policy
differences
those policy difference cannot be
utilized to destroy the separation of
powers house manager spoke for I know
we've had disagreements on the time it
was 21 hours or 23 hours they spoke
during their time a lot of time most of
it attacking the president policy
decisions they didn't like what they
heard they didn't like there was a pause
on foreign aid I'd laid out before that
there was pauses on all kinds of foreign
aid it's not the first president to do
it but the one thing I'm still trying to
understand from the managers perspective
maybe it's not fair to ask the managers
because you're not the you know the
leader of the of the house but remember
the whole idea that this was a dire
national security threat a danger to our
nation we had to get this over here
right away it had to be done before
Christmas it was so important was so
significant the country was in such
jeopardy so serious that it had to be
done immediately let's hold on to the
articles impeachment for a month to see
if this house could force the Senate to
adopt rules that they wanted which is
not the way the Constitution is set up
but but it was such a dire emergency it
was so critical for our nation's
national interest that we could hold
them for 33 days Danger Danger Danger
that's politics
as I said you're being called upon to to
remove the duly elected president of the
United States that's what these articles
of impeachment call for they never
really answered the question of why they
thought there was such a national
emergency maybe they will
during questions I don't know there was
such a national emergency they never did
explain why it was that they waited they
didn't wait to have the proceedings as
my colleagues have laid out I mean those
proceedings it moved in record time
I suspect that we've been here more than
the the house actually considered the
actual articles of impeachment is that
the way the Constitution is supposed to
work is that the design of the
Constitution
and then their question of course came
up and and yesterday on the whole
situation with Purisima and the Biden's
and that whole issue and my colleagues
went through that a great deal and I'm
not going to do that but do we have a
like are we in a situation do we have a
like are we in a situation we used to
call this in free speech cases like a a
free speech zone you could have your
free speech activities over here you
can't have them over there do we have
like a a Biden free zone and what was
that what this was that there was it's
it's a you you mentioned someone and
it's now off limits you can impeach the
president the United States for asking a
question I think we significantly showed
the question I'm not going to go through
a detail by detail analysis of the facts
but there are some that we just have to
go through you you heard a lot of new
facts yesterday in our presentation
Saturday what we were pointing to is a
very quick overview and then yesterday
we spent the day and we appreciate
everybody's patience on that going
through the facts they showed you this
but they didn't show you that the facts
the applause facts have legal
ramifications legal ramifications impact
the decisions you make so I don't take
facts lightly and I certainly don't take
the constitutional mandate it's lightly
and we can the facts we demonstrated
yesterday briefly on Saturday
demonstrate that there was in fact a
proper governmental interest in the
questions that the president asked and
the issues that the president raised on
that phone call a phone call now let's
again put your shoes in the put your
feet in the shoes of the president put
yourself in the president's position do
you think he thought when he was on the
call it was him and president Solinsky
he was talking to and that was it
it was as sometimes I heard one
commentator said it was people listening
in on the call the president and 3,000
of his closest friends let's be
realistic the president the United
States knew when he was on that call
there were a lot of people listening
from our side and from their side so he
knew what he was saying
saying he said it we released a
transcript of it the facts on the call
that had been kind of the focus of all
of this really focused on foreign policy
initiatives both in Ukraine and around
the globe they taught other countries
and other countries the president has
been very concerned about other
countries carrying some of the financial
load here not just the United States
that's a legitimate position for a
president to take if you disagree with
it you have the right president as my
colleague deputy white House Counsel
Feldman just said that's the executive
branch prerogative that is their
constitutional appropriate role so the
call is well documented there were lots
of people on the call the person that
would be on the other end of the quid
pro quo if it existed would have been
present at the end of the quid pro quo
if it existed would have been president
Solinsky but president Solinsky and we
already laid out the other officials
from Ukraine have repeatedly said there
was no pressure it was a good call aid
all of that is well documented I'm not
going to go through each and every one
of those facts we did that over the last
several days president solinsky's senior
advisor Andre year Mac was asked if he
ever felt there was a connection between
military aid in the
Westford invent that we never had that
feeling and we did not have the feeling
that this aide was connected to any one
specific issue this is coming from the
people who were receiving the aid so we
talked about this whole quid pro quo and
that was a big issue that's how this
actually before it became a impeachment
proceeding there was as the proceedings
were beginning in house permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence under
chairmanships role there was all these
discussions is it a quid pro quo was it
was it extortion was it bribery what was
it and we are we are clear in our
position that there was no quid pro quo
but then yesterday my co-counsel
Professor Alan Dershowitz explained last
night that these articles must be
rejected he's talking about from a
constitutional framework I mean if there
was a quid pro quo which we have clearly
established there was not and this is
what he said and I'm gonna quote it
verbatim the claim that foreign policy
decisions can be deemed abuses of power
based on subjective opinions about mixed
were sole motives that the president was
interested only in helping himself dim
demonstrate the dangers of employing the
vague subjective and politically
malleable phrase abuse of power as a
constitutionally permissible criteria
for the removal of a president he went
on to say now it follows from this that
if a president any president have done
what The Times reported about the
content of John Bolton's manuscript that
would not constitute an impeachable
offense I'm quoting exactly from
Professor Durst which he says let me
repeat it nothing in the Boulton
revelations even if true even if true
would rise to the level of abuse of
power or an impeachable offense that'll
offense that is clear from history that
is clear from the language of the
Constitution you cannot turn conduct
that is not impeachable into impeachable
conduct simply by using words like quid
pro quo and personal benefit it is
inconceivable that the framers would
have ended so so politically loaded and
promiscuously deployed a term as abuse
of power to be weaponized again
professor gerschwitz as a toll of a tool
of impeachment it is precisely the kind
of vague open-ended and subjective term
the founders and the framers feared and
rejected now to be specific
you cannot impeach a president on an
unsourced allegation but what professor
Dershowitz are saying even if everything
in there was true it constitutionally
doesn't rise to that level but I want to
be clear on this clear on this because
there's a lot of speculation out there
with regard to what John Bolton has said
which referenced a number of individuals
we'll start with the president here's
what the president said in response to
that New York Times piece
I never told John Bolton that the age
Ukraine was tied to investigations into
Democrats including the Biden's in fact
he never complained about this at the
time of his very public termination if
john bolton said this it was only to
sell a book the department of justice
while the Department of Justice has not
reviewed mr. Bolton's manuscript the New
York Times account of his conversation
grossly mischaracterizes what Attorney
General bar and bar and Bolton discussed
there was no discussion of personal
favors or undue influence on
investigations nor did the Attorney
General state that the president's
conversations with foreign leaders were
improper the vice president's chief of
staff issued a statement in every
conversation with the president
the vice-president in preparation for
our trip to Poland remember that was the
trip that with president Solinsky the
president consistent consistently
expressed his frustration that the
United States was bearing the lion's
share of responsibility for age Ukraine
and that European nations weren't doing
their part the president also expressed
concerns about corruption in Ukraine and
at no time to him tie Ukraine aid to
investigations into the Biden family or
verismo that was the response
responding to an unpublished manuscript
that maybe some reporters have an idea
of maybe what it says that's what the
evidence if you want to call that
evidence I don't know what you'd call
that I call it an admissible but that's
what it is
to argue that the president is not
acting in our national interest and is
violating his oath of office which the
managers have put forward is wrong based
on the facts and Bey the way the
constitute based on the facts and Bey
the way the Constitution is designed and
when you look at the fullness of the
record of their witnesses their
witnesses the witnesses statements the
transcripts
there's one thing that emerges law
there's no a violation of the
Constitution there is a disagreement on
policy decisions most of those that
spoke at your hearings did not like the
president's policy that's why we have
elections that's what policy
differentials and patrols and
differences are discussed but to have
have a removal of a duly elected
president based on a policy disagreement
that is not what the framers intended
and if you lower the bar that way Danger
Danger Danger because the next president
or the one app he or she would be held
to that same standard I hope not I pray
not that that's not what happens not
just for the sake of of my client but
for the Constitution Constitution you
know professor Dershowitz gave a list of
presidents from Washington to where we
are today who under that standard that
they are proposing could be subject to
abuse of power or obstruction of
Congress look we know that what is not
about a president pausing aid to Ukraine
it's really not about a phone call it's
about a lot of attempts on policy
disagreements that are not being debated
here my goodness how much time how much
much time
has been spent in the House of
Representatives hoping they were hoping
that the Muller probe would result in me
I'm not gonna play I was thinking about
it playing all the clips from all the
commentators the day after a after the
day after the bomb mullah testified my
mother was unable to answer under his
examination basic and fundamental
questions here to correct himself
actually here to correct himself before
the Senate for something he said before
the house so that's what the president's
been living with and then we're here
today arguing about what a phone call to
Ukraine or Ukraine aid being held or a
question about corruption or a question
about corruption that happens to involve
a high public profile figure I mean is
that what this is is that where we are
and is that where we are and then what
do we find out the aid was released it
was released in an orderly fashion the
reform president presidents whether his
party would take the parliament it did
they worked late into the evening with
the desire to put forward reforms so
everybody was waiting including and you
heard the testimony from I will say
their witnesses you heard the testimony
everybody was concerned about Ukraine
everybody was concerned about whether
these reforms could actually take place
concerned about it so you hold back
didn't affect anything that was going on
in the field we heard mister crow
worrying about the soldiers I understand
that I appreciate that but none of that
aid was affecting what was going on on
the battlefield right then or for the
next four months because it was future
aid
and are we having an impeachment
proceeding because aid came out three
weeks before the end of the fiscal year
or a six-minute phone call you boil it
down that's what this is it's
interesting that everybody saying well
the aid was finally released September
11th only because of the committee and
the whistleblower who we've never seen
mr. Philbin dealt with that in great
detail not going to go over that again
but you know the new High Court the
anti-corruption courts an established
and did not sit until September 5th 2019
so while the president of Ukraine was
trying to get reforms put in place the
court that was going to decide
corruption issues was not set until
September 5th how much I want you to
think about this for a moment - they
needed a high court of corruption for
corruption I would think about that from
now that's good that they wreck about
that from now that's good that they
recognized it but remember when I said
the other day you don't make wave a
magic wand and now Ukraine doesn't have
a corruption problem the high court of
corruption which they have to have
because it's not just they're concerned
about ongoing corruption issues and you
could put all of your witnesses back on
the under oath in the next hearings
you'll have when this is all over and
you're going to be back in the house and
we'll be doing this again put them all
back under oath and ask them mr. Schiff
is there a problem of corruption in
Ukraine and if they get up there and say
no everything is great now everything is
great now hallelujah but I suspect
they're gonna say we're working really
hard on it and I believe them but this
idea
that it was just vanished and now we're
back in - everything's fine it's absurd
surd
mr. Marson testified that while the
developments were taking place the vice
president also met with President
Solinsky in Warsaw that was the meeting
of September 1st the one by the way
where the vice president's office said
in response to this New York Times see
nobody told him about aid being held or
linked to investigations are you gonna
stop are you going to allow proceedings
on impeachment to go from a New York
Times report about someone that says
what they hear is in a manuscript is
that where we are I don't think so I
hope not what did Marcin say he heard
firsthand that the new Ukraine
administration was taking concrete steps
to address corruption that's good
he advised the president that the
relationship with szalinski is one that
could be trusted
good presidents and whiskey also agreed
with Vice Premier peon should be doing
more and related to vice president pence
conversations he'd been having with
European leaders about getting them to
do more in some the president raised two
issues he was concerned with to get them
addressed now I've already went over
this is just the closing moments here of
this proceeding of our portion of this
proceeding aid was withheld or paused
put on a pause button
not just for Ukraine
Afghanistan South Korea El Salvador
Honduras Guatemala Lebanon in Pakistan
and I'm sure I am leaving countries out
but do you think the American people are
concerned if the president says you know
before we give a country I don't know
five hundred and fifty million dollars
some countries only four hundred million
dollars
we'd like to know what they're doing
with it you're supposed to be the
guardians of the trust here it's the
taxpayers money we're spending
there was a lot of testimony from from
dr. Fiona Hill John Bolton's deputy
here's what she said about aid was being
held this is her testimony there was a
pre put freeze put on all kinds of aid
and assistance because it was in the
process at the time of a awful lot of
reviews of foreign assistance oh you
mean there was a policy within the
administration to review foreign
assistance in how we're doing it because
we spend a lot of money and by the way
I'm not complaining about them I don't
think anybody doesn't want to help but
we do need to but we do need to know
what's going on and those are valid and
important questions manager crow told
you that president the president's
Ukraine policy was not strong against
Russia but ambassador Jovanovic stated
the exact opposite she said in her
deposition that our countries Ukraine
policy under President Trump actually
her words got stronger than it was under
President Obama
so again policy disagreements
disagreements on approach have elections
that's what we do in our republic for
three long days house managers by
selectively showing parts of testimony
good lawyers show parts of testimony you
don't have to show the whole thing but
other good lawyers show the rest of the
testimony and that's what we sought to
do to give you a fuller view of what we
saw as the glaring omissions by my
colleagues the house managers
the legal issues here are the
constitutional ones and I have been I
think pretty clear over the last week
starting when we had the motions
arguments about the constitutional
obligations that we're operating under I
have been critical of manager Nadler x'
executive privilege and other nonsense
we I want you to look at it this way
take out executive privilege First
Amendment free speech and other nonsense
the free the free exercise of religion
and other nonsense the rights to due
process and other nonsense the rights
equal protection under the laws and
other nonsense you can't start doing
that you would not do that no
administration has done that in fact
since the first administration George
Washington they wanted information he
thought it was privileged he said it was
executive privilege but let's not start
calling constitutional rights other
nonsense lumping them together
course this is from from a House of
Representatives actually believes the
attorney-client privilege doesn't apply
which should scare every lawyer in
Washington DC but we're more scary to
the lawyers will be for their clients
they say that in writing in letters I
don't hide it I would ask them
I don't going to it's not my privilege
to do that do you really believe that do
you really believe that the
attorney-client privilege does not apply
in a congressional hearing
do you really believe that because then
if it doesn't apply then there is no
attorney-client privilege the
attorney-client privilege and other
nonsense Danger Danger Danger
we believe that article one fails
constitutionally the president has
constitutional authority to
constitutional authority to engage and
conduct foreign policy and foreign
affairs it is our position legally
president at all times acted with
perfect legal authority inquired of
matters in our national interest and
having received assurances of those
matters continued his policy that his
administration put forward of what
really is unprecedented for Ukraine
including the delivery of military aid
package that was denied to the
Ukrainians by prior administration's you
know something some of the managers
right here my colleagues at the other
table voted in favor of those wanted
javelin anti-tank missiles for Ukraine
some of them some of the members here
did not didn't want to do that voted
against that I'm glad we gave it to him
I'm glad we allowed them to purchase
javelins I told you I never served in
the military I have tremendous
tremendous respect for the men and women
that protect our freedom each and every
day I
tremendous respect for what they are
doing and continue to do but this
president actually allowed the javelins
to do some of you like that idea some of
you did not its policy difference
were you gonna impeach President Obama
because he did not give them lethal aid
lethal aid no nor should of you you
should not do that it's a policy
difference policy difference do not rise
to the level of constitutionally
mandated or constitutional applications
for removal from office it is policy
differences by the way it's not just on
lethal weapons then President Obama's I
said withheld aid he had the right to do
that you've allowed him to do that oh
but we don't like that this president
did it so the rule so this president's
rules are different than he he has a
different set of standards he has to
apply than what you allowed the previous
administration to apply and you know
what or the future administration to
apply that's the problem with these
articles we've laid out I believe a
compelling case on what the Constitution
requires wires when they were in the
House of Representatives putting this
together did they go through a
constitutionally mandated accommodations
process to see if there was a way to
come up with something no they did not
did they run to court no and the one
time no and the one time it was about to
happen they ran the other way
separation powers mean something it's
not separation of powers and other
nonsense if we've reached now it in the
history of our Republic a bar of
impeachment because you don't like the
president's policies you don't like the
way he undertook those policies because
we heard a lot about policies if
partisan impeachment is now the rule
which these members and members of this
Senate said should never be the rule of
the day my goodness they said it some of
them five months ago but then we had the
national emergency a phone call it's an
emergency
except well we look just wait
but a partisan impeachment based on
policy disagreements which is what this
is and personal presumptions or
newspaper reports and allegations in a
unsourced maybe this is in somebody's
book who's no longer at the White House
that becomes the new norm future
presidents Democrats Republicans will be
paralyzed the moment they are elected
before they can even take the oath of
office the bar for impeachment cannot be
set this low Majority Leader McConnell
Democratic leader Schumer house managers
members of the Senate Danger Danger
Danger these articles must be rejected
the Constitution requires it justice
demands it majority leader we would ask
for a short recess if we can about 15
minutes the majority leader is
recognized we'll be in recess for 15 15
minutes without objection
Senate impeachment trial in a 15 minute
break now we heard from the White House
defense team that when they return after
this break you will hear from White
House glowny and he will conclude the
president's opening arguments they have
had three days to make their opening
arguments 24 hours and it turns out that
they will use about half of that time we
want to get your reaction to what you
have heard and we are expecting some
senators and possibly the house managers
maybe even the president's attorneys go
to the different cameras positioned
throughout the capital on the Senate
side so when we see one of them approach
we will go to that in the meantime we
want to take your phone calls Democrats
202
seven four eight eight nine to zero
Republicans 202 nine to one all others
202 seven four eight eight nine to two
remember you can text us as well at 202
seven four eight eight zero zero three
just have to remember to put your first
name city and state now
while the White House attorneys were
making their concluding remarks of their
opening arguments Alan Dershowitz who we
all heard from last night in the Senate
impeachment trial Senate impeachment
trial was tweeting at the same time and
he sent out this tweet referring to
senator Elizabeth Warren in her comments
about not following his arguments last
night he said Warren doesn't understand
the law my former colleague senator
Warren claims she could not follow my
carefully laid out presentation that
everybody else seemed to understand this
this says more about Warren than it does
about me and then he also said she also
willfully mischaracterized what I said
claiming that I spoke about intent I
challenged her to find that word
anywhere in my presentation I talked
about the difficulty of discerning mixed
motives he also said this if Warren knew
anything about criminal law she would
understand the distinction between
motives which are not elements of crime
it's the responsibility of presidential
candidates to have a better
understanding of the law the two of them
Harvard law professors together at one
time Alan Dershowitz still professor
there as we've said our c-span's Craig
Kaplan our Capitol Hill producer is in
the chamber Dean during these
proceedings during these proceedings and
here are a couple tweets from him
observations that he made inside the
Senate impeachment trial date which
started a few minutes late at a 103 p.m.
of its scheduled 1:00 p.m. start time 20
to 30 senators on both sides of the
aisle were missing with Chief Justice
Roberts gaveled the trial back into
session he also noticed that Michigan
GOP represented fought a member of the
president's impeachment team is on the
Senate floor seated in the back of the
chamber on the GOP seat watching the
impeachment trial from reporters on
Capitol Hill John Bresnahan of Politico
tweeting out that Senate Republicans are
expected to meet today after the
president's lawyers finish up their
presentation their presentations so
after we hear from Pat's abalone
Republicans are expected to go behind
closed doors and deliberate about what's
next Maggie Haberman from the New York
Times who's had some breaking news as
you all know over the past couple of
days along with Michael Schmitt tweeting
out that the president sounds resigned
to having witnesses and sees it as
likely in conversations with people his
team meanwhile Republican senators that
the White House lawyers weren't aware of
the substance of what is in Bolton's
book now also political reporting that
Lindsey Graham supports the play a plan
to let senators view Bolton's transcript
however roll call is reporting that
getting a subpoena for that transcript
proved difficult as that there would be
intellectual property rights issues with
that and then you also have Senator Rand
Paul today and this quote from the
Washington Post torching Bolton as a
quote disgruntled fired employee let's
listen to what senator gray
had to say earlier today about witnesses
and John Bolton here's what I met on
witnesses I am ready to make my decision
based on the record established in the
house the house chose not to pursue
witnesses that were available to him I
don't want to start a precedent of just
doing it half-assed in the house and
expect the Senate to fix it
I've seen the narottam's story I have no
idea of what they're talking about
senator Lankford has suggested to make
it the manuscript available in a
classified setting and let senators go
read it for themselves that sounds like
a reasonable solution to me
however if people want witnesses we're
going to get a lot of witnesses this
idea of calling one and one makes zero
sense to me say is it there's not a
scintilla of evidence that the Biden's
connection to the Ukraine was
inappropriate there's a tsunami of
evidence so the house managers told the
Senate this is baseless has been
debunked and I think the defense team
yesterday made a damning indictment of
Hunter and Joe Biden allowed to happen
and it's not in America's interest to
ever see this happen again in the
Ukraine where hunter Biden basically
turned it into an ATM machine we're
going to go to that and there's media
reports people in your business have
suggested that a DNC staffer met with
Ukrainian officials about the 2016
election I don't know if that's true or
not but if we're going to open this up
to additional inquiry
inquiry we're going to go down the road
was it legitimate for the president to
believe there was corruption and
conflicts of interest on the Biden's
part in the Ukraine fully explore that
and whether or not there's any
credibility the idea that the DNC may
have been working with Ukraine
so what is your going to be on that
opening opening question of whether
there should be a witness - I am I am I
will let you know Friday but right now I
feel comfortable with the idea I have
enough and I'm just telling everybody
who thinks you can surgically deal with
this it's not going to happen I'll make
a prediction
there'll be 51 Republican votes to call
hunter Biden Joe Joe Biden The
Whistleblower and the DNC staffer at a
very minimum well I've said basically
what they proved to me it would have
been wrong Trump not to raise this issue
you have to be willfully blind and say
that democratic misconduct doesn't
matter to you
not to believe that the President had a
good reason to ask the Ukraine to look
into the Biden affair you had media
reports right before the July 25th
meeting as much as I like Joe Biden he
needs to answer questions of why he
allowed his son to continue to receive
billions of dollars from burry smih when
he seen you to receive billions of
dollars from burry smih when he should
have known it was a conflict of interest
if a Republican had been in that same
situation you would be all over all of
us wanting to know why we're not calling
these people as witnesses so as much as
I like Joe Biden he has to answer
version efforts in the Ukraine
apparently it's in a classified setting
now I'm just suggesting if it's in a
classified setting now let's look at it
in that setting this was senator
Lankford's idea it makes perfect sense
to me I don't know if it's achievable
but that would be a solution to the
problem
Senator Lindsey Graham from earlier
today talking to reporters on witnesses
and calling witnesses the headline in
the hill newspaper this morning that the
majority leader Mitch McConnell
struggles to maintain GOP unity post the
news from that manuscript to John
Bolton's book also Olivia Bevers on a
reporter saying senator Braun says he
does not feel need to see Bolton
manuscript because his he notes
Dershowitz argued yesterday that even if
the claims made in the book are true
they don't rise to the level of an
impeachable offense happening out on
Capitol Hill outside the Senate chamber
House Republicans who are part of the
president's defense team talking to
reporters but to think the articles of
impeachment will come over here and hype
will come over here and hijack the
Senate the way it has and they say a
thousand times over no one's above the
law and they don't even accuse the
president of breaking any law it's time
to move on and it's time to move forward
and I'll leave you with this just
imagine happen in our country if you
play this out
not just long-term not just the next
time that you have a Republican house
with a Democratic president and this new
lowered standard what happens the next
day I care about our republic my
backgrounds in the military still serve
in the Army Reserve add 82nd Airborne
Division Elise represents Fort Drum
we have people who go overseas for their
10th deployment they might have a four
year old and a six year old at home why
do they make that sacrifice why are they
willing to lay down their life for our
flag for our freedoms for our Liberty
for option
ruler will the risk at all not just for
friends and family but for strangers all
of you as Patriots regardless of whether
you're in Congress you're a member of
the media or you're watching at home
think about what this means for America
the next day it's time to move on
happy to be answering to answer any
questions you have
well so first off the standard the
burden of proof is not on the President
to prove his innocence now there are
many members of the House who said that
the president is guilty until he proves
his innocence that's not the American
Way but the very first person who came
to testify gave a transcribed interview
former special envoy ukraine kurt volker
and if you go right back to his
deposition his transcript to start this
whole thing off he said that the
readouts from Ukraine and the u.s. after
the July 25th call make no reference to
quid pro quo or a hold on aid that the
next day on July 26 Kurt Volker meets
with President Solinsky there's no
reference to quid pro quo or hold on aid
for weeks that follow with all of the
contacts between ambassador Volcker and
President szalinski and his top aides
there's no reference to quid pro quo or
a hold on aid and not just Kurt Volker
and Bill Taylor George Kent and others
the people were actually in touch with
president Solinsky in his top team they
all say the president Solinsky didn't
know that there was a hold on aid until
after reading in Politico at the very
end of August the hold on aid gets
released shortly thereafter and Ukraine
didn't have to do anything new in order
to get that hold on aid lifted these
facts we're actually the very first
facts that we learned with the very
first illness in front of Adam Schiff
none of those witnesses that you heard
in the house were in the room with the
President or I've had a conversation
which President so why don't they want
to hear like john-boy
you know actually uh ambassador Volker
did have direct conversations with the
President of the United States of the
United States and to that point one
other let me just let me just answer it
because because ambassador Volker has
you know he did speak but on top of that
going back to the fall of 2017 President
Trump was directly expressing his
concern to ambassador Volker of the need
to fight corruption in Ukraine away from
the House Republicans take you over to
another camera Senator Richard
Blumenthal Democrat of Connecticut
talking to reporters was a free
summation
a taste bereft of evidence you need the
evidence we need the witnesses and
documents they may have the votes at
this moment
but I hope my colleagues will work
themselves in the mirror and
and what do you think
what we want is the truth not some quid
pro quo on witnesses we see what a quid
pro quo
does indeed the truth and we need the
witnesses who were in the room eyes and
mouth on the present the first am Holly
beginning with John holding all the
documents is notes so that the American
people can see the complete story
not a trump campaign ad on the Florida
Senate which is what a
our view is we want all four witnesses
John Bolton
Robert Blair
all of them
with relevant firsthand on and the
documents that we've provided above
whether it's one by one or in totally
we'd like votes on already finished on
I'm deeply alarmed and concerned and
again it reflects the diminishing
leadership of this president and his
credibility which is we so reduced by
his essentially lack of Odyssey
nothing people but the potential for a
way to be integrated into the UK system
is deeply concerning concerning and I
hope they'll be stronger action
I hope it will not because I hope the UK
will be better of this potentially very
misguided and
possibly reckless move thank you get to
some calls here Shirley in Arkansas
Europe for a democratic color your
reaction to what you've heard today well
I voted Democrat for 59 years but with
all that's going on I'll never ever vote
for Democrats they're corrupt they're
they're making us become a third world
country and I will never as long as as
long as I live
even though I'm 80 years old I will
never vote Democrat ever again because
of what you've heard in this in Petri it
yes and and why what specifically
Oh crooked they're so crooked okay
Shirley dug in Cal independent dug your
turn hi thank you for taking my call
the whistleblower is what is on my mind
I believe nobody has ever seen a
whistleblower nobody knows the
whistleblower except for mr. Allen shift
and I'm just beginning to wonder if
Allen shift is the whistleblowers it's
Adam Schiff Lord it's Adam Schiff the
chair of the Intelligence Committee from
California now the Senate is past their
break time they broke it to 18 or we're
coming up on the pet of the end of their
break time the Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell is we saw him walking back
into the chamber so cameras when they
come up when the cameras come up that is
when we will go right back into the
chamber who may have to cut off your
remarks so we can get you back in there
quickly as they resumed their concluding
remarks from the president's lawyers now
we're expected to hear from paths
abalone he said he will not take all of
their 24 hours they'll take about half
of it and he said that conclude by
dinner time if not before let's go to
Danny and Inglis Florida Republican
caller Danny hello Danny let me try one
more time here
daniyar there yeah I'm here alright go
ahead but you know Trump said he was
gonna run on the basis of brilliant
bases or bringing in the swamp and I've
never drank I worked construction for 50
years and you don't drain the swamp
without letting the water and there's a
lot of Democrats fixing to wash over to
them so that's that's my opinion on it
all right Danny Danny in Florida now
after we hear the conclusion and lawyers
opening remarks this afternoon what the
hill is reporting that Senate
Republicans are going to meet behind
closed doors that the majority leader
Mitch McConnell according to two sources
the he has called the meeting to get his
GOP colleagues on the same page as phase
one of the impeachment trial nears its
end under the under the trials
organizing resolution which McConnell
drafted senators will then have 16 hours
to ask questions of the house managers
and the president's lawyers before
voting on whether it should be in order
to subpoena additional witnesses such as
the former national security advisor
john bolton and acting White House chief
of staff Mick Mulvaney now they will
meet behind closed doors and then
they're expected questioning of the
house managers and the president's
lawyers tomorrow that is what is being
reported by reporters up on Capitol Hill
Kimberly in Philadelphia Democratic
caller hi hi my my concern is that the
practice of the GOP systematically
blocking information from the public is
is not served blocking information from
the public is is not serving as well no
one including the president is above the
law the GOP has basically been acting as
if their role is to defend the Pope
president and oppose his agenda starting
with the holding of legislate since the
president has been in office the GOP has
basically been upholding his agenda as
opposed to appearing as if they're
working for the public as each senator
is to be now regarding these charges and
the impeachment and we've heard all
sorts of claims that the impeachment is
invalid as if it's not defined by our
Constitution each of our elected
officials including the president is
expected to serve a particular role in
upholding our Constitution and that does
not seem to be happening they determined
before the trial even started and
identified themselves as biased jurors
imagine that imagine that never have we
seen any such behavior and claim and
willingness to to stand up and say that
and as it will be accepted by the
American people okay Kimberly and more
observations from c-span's Capitol Hill
producer Craig Kaplan Senate floor desk
mates senators Collins and Murkowski
speech other for a few minutes in their
seats at the top of the recess Collins
Dylan then went over and spoke to Jerry
Nadler one of the house managers seated
at the managers table he returned to
trial today after being in New York City
Monday where his wife is undergoing
pancreatic cancer treatment Michael in
Granada Hills California independent hi
Michael
hi there thank you for providing the
coverage they very much appreciate it I
think the biggest issue and I think the
biggest issue right now is that when you
go to trial you have to be tried for
breaking a law and you have to have
evidence missing anybody in your
community who has gone to civil or
criminal trial contest - that to me that
has and I think the witnesses and press
statements all just take away from that
I think those needs to stop and they
need to be resubmitted under
constitutionally correct needs okay
Michael Lee Ann called way who Caldwell
who produces for NBC tweeting out just
after the break was called senators
Collins and Murkowski stayed seated and
chatted quietly for about for about five
minutes each at a hand covering their
mouth likely to assure that reporters or
perhaps other senators could pick up
what they had to say
Roger in New Mexico Republican hi Roger
again we're waiting for the Senate come
back in after this short recess we don't
control the cameras Roger so when they
come people go there quickly go ahead
all right first of all I thank you for
let me speaking on the opinion I do not
support the impeachment of a president
who has done more for an end domestic
that any president we've ever had in
history of the United States they've got
a problem with this policy or him
himself
it sounds like a personal issue but he
has done more more on foreign policy all
the deals that he has made everything
this man has done he's done and made
things better with the citizens and
people in the United States okay Roger
in New Mexico now Robert costo reports
for the Washington Post caught up with
Adam Schiff the lead house manager of
the Incheon Intel chair in the house
said he just interviewed him and on the
Bolton fallout as Robert Costas says in
his tweet and as the witness talks
continued Schiff holds his position no
circus deals in the Senate shouldn't
look to the house to issue a subpoena
for Bolton also from Capitol Hill we
have a Casey hunt who's saying senator
David Perdue has compared Romney to Jeff
Flake on steroids and steroids except
the Romney is not in danger of losing
his seat mitt romney as you all know
saying there are him and other
republicans who could be open to voting
for allowing witnesses and getting
testimony from john bolton on a lighter
note thomas burr who covers capitol hill
tweeting at romney is drinking chocolate
milk he apparently brought his own
bottle and then a Wall Street Journal
reporter Natalie Andrews says Mitt
Romney was busted for bringing a bottle
of BYU's famous chocolate milk on the
Senate floor he put it in a glass and
that was okay then we'll go to Joel in
California Democratic caller hi Joel hi
thank you for having me on yeah I guess
I guess my only reaction to the defense
so far has been it feels like they don't
have a coherent narrative or like a
logical progression so there are going
to
more or less like I would characterize
it as a constellation of randomly
indented bullet points whereas I think
the house managers laid out a very clear
argument where they went through
systematically through article one and
through article to article one through
article two and they they basically went
ahead with trying to prove their case in
a very systematic fashion the defense
just seemed to kind of just be spraying
whatever they can out there in the hopes
that I think somebody will latch on to
one and one or two things and that way
they'll be able to say oh this is my
reason for you know supporting the
defense rather than that there's a
logical conclusion or a logic you know I
don't know if they're allowed to have
visual aids on the floor of the Senate
but if they if they were I think it'd be
super helpful to have two different like
flip charts one that says article 1 1
that says article 2 and everything that
pertains to those two articles of
impeachment goes on the first two and
then a third one that's just everything
else well they've had that would be an
easy way yeah joe yeah Joel they both
the house managers and the president's
lawyers have used visual aids throughout
right yes they use slides and stuff like
that but if you had something that was
easy like visual reference where you
could see here's everything that doesn't
actually relate directly to article 1
abuse of power article 2 obstruction of
Congress and that way you'd know this
was like a shiny object just kind of
being thrown out as a way to I think
muddy the waters or confused people who
are watching that's what it feels like
the defense is trying to do they're just
trying to serve as much stuff out there
to confuse people and so that the latch
onto one or two things that they think
they like okay all right well the Senate
is in a fifteen minute break it's more
it's approaching more like thirty
minutes here and there we'll take this
break and then they'll come back and the
president's lawyers plan to wrap up
their opening argue their opening
arguments and then it turns to the
sixteen hours of questions that senators
get to ask they have to write down their
questions that get vetted through
leadership according to the hill
newspaper and then they are asked they
are given to the Chief Justice who then
reads the question to what whoever it's
addressed to during the Clinton trial
they would get five minutes to answer
each of those how it works out this time
around Jeff Zeleny who reports for CNN
tweeting out the Amy Klobuchar is making
a whirlwind trip to Iowa tonight up the
Senate is back in we'll go there now
Thank You mr. Chief Justice members of
the Senate well I had kind of a lengthy
presentation prepared the presentation
prepared but I think I think you've
heard a lot from our side and I think
we've made our case and so I just want
to leave you with a couple of points
first of all first of all Thank You mr.
leader and Thank You Democratic leader
Schumer and all of you for the privilege
for your time and attention we really
appreciate it
we've made three basic points one all
you need in this case is the
Constitution and your common sense you
just look at the articles of impeachment
the articles of impeachment fall far
short of any constitutional standard and
they are dangerous and if you look to
the words from the past that I think are
instructive as I said last night they're
instructive because they were right then
and there right now and I'll leave you
with some of those words they must never
be a narrowly voted impeachment or an
impeachment supported by one of our
major political parties and opposed by
the other such an impeachment will
produce the device of this and
bitterness in our politics for years to
come and we'll call into question the
very legitimacy of our political
institutions this is an American people
by these actions you would undo the free
elections that express the will of the
American people in 1996 in so doing you
will damage the faith the American
people have in this institution and in
the American democracy you will set the
dangerous precedent that the certainty
of presidential terms which is so
benefited our wonderful America will be
replaced by the partisan use of
impeachment than Pietschmann future
presidents will face election they
litigation then impeachment the power of
the president will diminish in the face
of the Congress a phenomena much feared
by the founding fathers this is a
constitutional amendment that we are
debating not an impeachment resolution
Lucien the Republicans are crossing out
the impeachment standard of high crimes
and misdemeanors and they are inserting
the words any crime or misdemeanor we
are permitting a constitutional
constitutional coup d'etat which will
our country forever I warn my colleagues
that you will reap the bitter harvest of
the unfair partisan seeds you sow today
the constitutional provision for
impeachment is a way to protect our
government and our citizens not another
weapon in the political arsenal I expect
history will show that we've lowered the
bar on impeachment so much we have
broken the seal on this extremely
extreme extreme penalty so cavalierly
that it will be used as a routine tool
to fight political battles my fear is
that when the Republican wins the White
House Democrats will demand payback you
were right
but I'm sorry to say you were also
prophetic and I think I couldn't say it
better myself so I won't you know what
the right answer is in your heart you
know what the right answer is for our
country you know right what the right
answer is for the American people what
American people what they are asking you
to do is to throw out a successful
president on the eve of an election with
no basis and in violation of the
Constitution
it would dangerously change our country
and weaken weakened forever all of our
democratic institutions American people
why not trust the American people with
this decision why tear up their balance
why tear up every ballot across this
country you can't do that you know you
can't do that so I ask you to defend our
Constitution to defend fundamental
fairness to defend basic due process
rights but most importantly most
importantly to respect and defend the
sacred right of every American to vote
and to choose their president the
election is only months away the
American people are entitled to choose
their president choose their president
overturning the last election and
massively interfering with the upcoming
one would cause serious and lasting
damage to the people of the United
States and to our great country the
Senate cannot have to happen it is time
for this to end here and now so we urge
the Senate to reject these articles of
impeachment for all of the reasons we
have given you you know them all I don't
need to repeat them they've repeatedly
said open a quote from bridge Benjamin
Franklin it's a republic if you can keep
it and every time I heard it I said to
myself it's a republic if they let us
keep it and I have every confidence
every confidence in your wisdom you will
do the only thing you can do what you
must do what the Constitution compels
you to do reject these articles of
impeachment for our country and for the
American people
it will show that you put the
Constitution above partisanship it will
show that we can come together on both
sides of the aisle and and the era of
impeachment for good you know it should
end you know it should end
it will allow you all to spend all of
your energy and all of your enormous
talent and all of your resources on
doing what the American people sent you
here to do to work together to work with
the President to solve their problems so
this should end now as quickly as
possible thank you for your attention I
look forward to answering your questions
and with that that ends our presentation
thank you very much mr. Chief Justice I
have reached mr. Chief Justice I have
reached an agreement with the Democratic
leader on how to proceed during the
question period therefore I ask
unanimous consent that the question
period for senators start when the
Senate reconvenes on Wednesday further
that the questions alternate between the
majority and minority sides for up to
eight out during that session of the
Senate finally that on Thursday the
Senate resume time for senators and
questions alternating between sides for
up to eight hours during that session of
the Senate so we will complete the
question period over the next two days
remind senators that their questions
must be in writing will be submitted to
the Chief Justice during the question
period of the Clinton trial senators
were a thoughtful and brief with their
questions and the managers and counsel
were succinct in their answers I hope we
can follow both of these examples during
this time
in the impeachment trial of President
Clinton Chief Justice Rehnquist advised
council quote counsel on both sides that
the chair will operate on a rebuttable
presumption that each question can be
fully and fairly answered and answered
in five minutes or less and quote the
transcript indicates that the statement
was met with quote laughter unquote
nonetheless managers and counsel
generally limited their responses
accordingly I think the late Chiefs time
limit was a good one and would ask both
sides to abide by it so mr. Chief
Justice I ask unanimous consent that the
trial adjourn until 1:00 p.m. when p.m.
Wednesday January 29th and that this
order also constituted the adjournment
of the Senate without objection were
adjourned
and with that the president's lawyers
have wrapped up their opening
distinguished members of the Senate our
friends lawyers fellow lawyers it's a
great honor for me to stand before you
today to present a constitutional
argument against the impeachment and
removal not only of this president but
of all and any future presidents who may
be charged with the unconstitutional
grounds of abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress I stand before
you today as I stood in 1973 in 1974 for
the protection of the constitutional and
procedural rights of Richard Nixon who I
personally abhorred and whose
impeachment
I personally favored and as I stood for
the rights of Bill Clinton who I admired
and whose impeachment I strongly opposed
I stand against the application and
misapplication of the constitutional
criteria in every case and against any
president without regard to whether I
support his or her party's or policies I
would be making the very same
constitutional argument had Hillary
Clinton for whom I voted been elected
and had a Republican House voted to
impeach her on these unconstitutional
grounds I am here today because I love
my country and our Constitution everyone
in this room shares that love I will
argue that our Constitution and its
terms high crimes and misdemeanors do
not encompass the two articles charging
abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress in offering these arguments I
stand in the footsteps and in the spirit
of justice Benjamin Curtis who was of
counsel to impeach President Andrew
Johnson and who explained to the Senate
that quote a greater principle was at
stake than the fate of any particular
president
and of William Everts a former Secretary
of State another one of Andrew Johnson's
lawyers who reportedly said that he had
come to the defense table not as a
partisan not as a sympathizer but to
defend the Constitution the Constitution
of course provides that the Senate has
the sole role and power to try all
impeachments and exercising that power
the Senate must consider three issues in
this case the first is whether the
evidence presented by the house managers
establishes by the appropriate standard
of proof proof beyond a reasonable doubt
that the factual allegations occurred
the second is whether if these factual
allegations occurred did they rise to
the level of abuse of power and/or
obstruction of Congress finally the
Senate must determine whether abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress are
constitutionally authorized criteria for
impeachment the first issue is largely
factual and I leave that to others the
second is a combination of traditional
and constitutional law and I will touch
on those the third is a matter of pure
constitutional law do charges of abuse
and obstruction rise to the level of
impeachable offenses under the
Constitution I will begin as all
constitutional analysis begins with the
text of the Constitution governing
impeachment
I will then examine why the framers
selected the words they did is the sole
criteria authorizing impeachment in
making my presentation I will transport
you back to a hot summer in Philadelphia
and a cold winter in Washington I will
introduce you to Patriots and ideas that
help shaped our great nation to prepare
for this journey I have immersed myself
in a lot of dusty old volumes from the
18th and 19th century I ask your
indulgence as I quote from the wisdom of
our founders this return to the days of
yesteryear is necessary because the
issue today is not what the criteria of
impeachment should be not what a
legislative
or a constitutional body might today
decide are the proper criteria for
impeachment of a president but what the
framers of our Constitution actually
chose and what they expressly and
implicitly rejected
I will ask whether the framers would
have accepted such vague and open-ended
terms as abuse of power and obstruction
of Congress as governing criteria I will
show by a close review of the history
that they did not end would not accept
such criteria for fear that these
criteria would turn our new republic
into a British style parliamentary
democracy in which the Chiefs executives
tenure would be in the words of James
Madison the father of our Constitution
at the pleasure of the legislature the
conclusion I will offer for your
consideration is similar though not
identical to that advocated by highly
respected justice Benjamin Curtis who as
you know dissented from the Supreme
Court's notorious decision in Dred Scott
and who after resigning in protest from
the High Court served as counsel to
President Andrew Johnson in the Senate
impeachment trial he argued and I quote
there can be no crime there can be no
misdemeanor without a law written or
unwritten express or implied in so
arguing he was echoing the conclusion
reached by Dean Theodore Dwight of the
Columbia Law School who wrote in 1867
just before the impeachment unless a
crime is specifically named in the
Constitution treason and bribery
impeachments like indictments can only
be instituted for crimes committed
against the statutory law of the United
States as as Judge Starr said earlier
today he described that as the weight of
authority being on the side of that
proposition at a time much closer to the
framing than we are today
the main thrust of my argument however
and the one most relevant to these
proceedings is that even if that
position is not accepted even if
criminal
conduct were not required the framers of
our Constitution implicitly rejected and
if it had been presented to them would
have explicitly rejected such vague
terms as abuse of power and obstruction
of Congress as among the enumerated and
defined criteria for impeaching a
president you will recall that among the
articles of impeachment against
President Johnson were accusations of
non criminal but outrageous misbehavior
including ones akin to the abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress for
example article 10 charged Johnson did
attempt to bring into disgrace ridicule
hatred and contempt and reproach the
Congress of the United States
article 11 charge Johnson with denying
that Congress was authorized by the
Constitution to exercise the legislative
power and denying that the legislation
of said Congress was obligatory upon him
pretty serious charges here's how
Justice Curtis responded to these non
criminal charges quote my first position
is that when Congress speaks of treason
bribery and other crimes and
misdemeanors it refers to and includes
only high criminal offenses against the
United States made so by some law of the
United States existing when the acts
complained of were done and I say he
continued that this is plainly to be
inferred from each and every one of the
provisions of the Constitution on the
subject of impeachment and I will
briefly review those other provisions of
the Constitution with you judge Curtiss
interpretation is supported indeed in
his view it was compelled by the
constitutional text treason bribery and
other Himes crimes and misdemeanors are
high crimes other high crimes and
misdemeanors must be akin to treason and
bribery curtis cited the latin phrase
noscitur I so see I'm sorry for the
mispronunciation referring to a classic
rule of interpretation that when the
meaning of a word that is part of a
group of words is uncertain you should
look to the other words in that group
that provide interpretive context the
the late Justice Anthony and Scalia gave
the following current example if one
speaks of Mickey Mantle Rock
marciano michael jordan and other great
competitors the last noun does not
reasonably refer to Sam Walton it was a
great competitor but in business or to
Napoleon a great competitor on the
battlefield applying that rule to the
groups of words treason bribery and
other high crimes and misdemeanors the
last five words should be interpreted to
include only serious criminal behavior
akin to treason and bribery just as
Curtis then reviewed the other
provisions of the Constitution that
relate to impeachment first he started
with the provision that says the
President of the United States shall
have the power to grant reprieves and
pardons listen now for offenses against
the United States except in cases of
impeachment he cogently argued that if
impeachment were not an offense against
the United States was not based on an
offense against the United States there
would have been no need for any
constitutional exception he then went on
to a second provision the trial of all
crimes except in cases of impeachment
shall be by jury this demonstrated
according to Curtis that impeachment
requires a crime but unlike other crimes
it does not require a jury trial you are
the judge and the jury he also pointed
out that impeachment trial by the
express words of the Constitution
requires an acquittal or a conviction
judgments generally rendered only in the
trial of crimes now President Johnson's
lawyers of course argued in the
alternative as all lawyers do when there
are questions of fact and of law he
argued that Johnson did not violate the
articles of impeachment as you've heard
from other lawyers today but even if he
did that the articles do not charge
impeachable offenses which is the
argument that I am making before you
this evening justice Curtis is first
position however was that the articles
did not charge an impeachable offense
because they did not allege high crime
offenses against the United States
according to a Harvard historian and law
professor Nicholas Bowie produces
constitutional arguments were persuasive
to at least some senators who were no
friends of President Johnson including
the co-authors of the 13th and the 14th
amendments as Senator William Pitt
Fessenden later put it judge Curtis gave
us the law and we followed it Senator
James W Grimes echoed curtis's argument
by refusing to accept an interpretation
of high crimes and misdemeanors that
changes according to the law of each
senators judgement enacted in his own
bosom after the alleged commission of
the offense though he desperately wanted
to see President Johnson who he despised
out of office he believed that an
impeachment and removal without the
violation of law would be quote
construed into approval of impeachment
as part of future political machinery
according to Professor Bowie justice
Curtis constitutional arguments may well
have contributed to the decision by at
least some of the seven Republican
dissidents to defy their party and vote
for acquittal which was secured by a
single vote now today professor Bowie
has an article in the New York Times in
which he repeats his view that quote
impeachment requires a crime but he now
argues that the articles of impeachment
do charge crimes he is simply wrong he
is wrong because in the United States
versus Hudson a case decided almost 200
more than 200 years ago now the United
States Supreme Court ruled that federal
courts have no jurisdiction to create
common law crimes crimes are only what
are in the statute book so professor
Bowie is right that the Constitution
requires a crime for impeachment but
wrong when he says that common law
crimes can be used as a basis for
impeaching even though they don't appear
in the statute books now I'm not here
arguing
that the current distinguished members
of the Senate are in any way bound
legally bound by justice curtis's
arguments or those of deemed white but I
am arguing that you should give them
serious consideration the consideration
to which they are entitled by the
eminence of their author and the role
they may have played in the outcome of
the closest precedent to the current
case now I want to be clear there's a
nuance difference between the arguments
made by Curtis and Dwight and the
argument that I am presenting here today
based on my reading of history Curtis
argued that there must be a specific
violation of pre-existing law he
recognized that at the time of the
Constitution there were no federal
criminal statutes of course not the
Constitution established the national
government so we couldn't have statutes
prior to the establishment of our
constitution and our nation this
argument is offered today by proponents
of this impeachment on the claim that
framers could not have intended to limit
the criteria to for impeachment to
criminal like behavior justice Curtis
addressed that issue and that argument
head-on he pointed out that crimes such
as bribery would be made criminal by the
laws of the United States which the
framers of the Constitution knew would
be passed in other words he anticipated
that Congress would soon enact statutes
punishing and defining crimes such as
burglary extortion perjury etc he
anticipated that and he based his
argument in part on that the
Constitution already included treason as
a crime and that was defined in the
Constitution itself and then it included
other crimes but what justice Curtis
said is that you could include laws
written or unwritten express or implied
by which he meant Konnan law which at
the time of the Constitution there were
many common law crimes and they were
enforceable even federally until the
Supreme Court many years later decided
that common law crimes were no longer
part
federal jurisdiction so the position
that I've derived from the history would
include and this is a word that has
upset some people but would include
criminal like conduct akin to treason
and bribery there need not be in my view
conclusive evidence of a technical crime
that would necessarily result in a
criminal conviction let me explain for
example if a president were to receive
or give a bribe outside of the United
States and outside of the statute of
limitations he could not technically be
prosecuted in the United States for such
a crime but I believe he could be
impeached for such a crime because he
committed the crime of bribery even
though he couldn't technically be
accused of it in the United States
that's the distinction that I think we
draw or if a president committed
extortion perjury or obstruction of
justice he could be charged with these
crimes as impeachable offenses because
these crimes though not specified in the
Constitution are akin to treason and
bribery this would be true even if some
of the technical elements time and place
were absent what Curtis and Dwight and I
agree upon and this is the key point in
this impeachment case please understand
what I'm arguing is that purely non
criminal conduct including abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress are
outside the range of impeachable
offenses that is the key argument I'm
presenting today this view was supported
by text writers and judges close in time
to the founding William old well Russell
who's 1819 treatise on criminal law was
a Bible among criminal law scholars and
others defined high crimes and
misdemeanors as quote such immoral and
unlawful acts as are nearly allied and
equal and guilt to a felony and yet
owing to the absence of some technical
circumstances technical circumstances do
not fall within the definition of a
felony similar views were expressed by
some state courts
disagree Kurtis considered views and
those of Dwight Russell and others based
on careful study of the text in history
are not bonkers absurdist legal crap
claptrap or other demeaning epithets
thrown around by partisan supporters of
this impeachment as Judge Starr pointed
out they had the weight of authority
they were accepted by the generation of
founders and the generations that
followed if they are not accepted by
academics today that shows a weakness
among the academics not among the
founders these who disagree with
curtis's textual analysis are obliged I
believe to respond with reasoned counter
interpretations not name-calling if
justice curtis's arguments in those of
Dean Dwight are rejected I think then
proponents of impeachment must offer
alternative principles alternative
standards for impeachment and removal we
just heard that in 1970 congressman
Gerald Ford who I greatly admired said
the following in the context of an
impeachment of a justice and impeachable
offenses whatever a majority of the
House of Representatives considered it
to be at a given moment in history etc
you all know the quote congresswoman
Maxine Waters recently put it more
succinctly in the context of a
presidential impeachment here's what she
said impeachment is whatever Congress
says it is there is no law but this
lawless view would place Congress above
the law it would place Congress above
the Constitution for Congress to ignore
the specific words of the Constitution
itself and substitute its own judgments
would be for Congress to do what it is
accusing the president of doing and no
one is above the law not the President
and not Congress
this is precisely the kind of view
expressly rejected by the framers who
feared having a president serve at the
pleasure of the legislature and it is
precisely the view rejected by Senator
James Grimes when he refused to accept
an interpretation of high crimes and
misdemeanors that would change according
to the law of each senators judgment
enacted in his own bosom the
Constitution requires in the words of
güven amoris that the criteria for
impeachment must be enumerated and
defined those who advocate and
Pietschmann today are obliged to
demonstrate how the criteria accepted by
the house in this case are enumerated
and defined in the Constitution the
compelling textual analysis provided by
Justice Curtis is confirmed by the
debate in the Constitutional Convention
by the Federalist Papers by the writings
of William Blackstone and I believe by
the writings of Alexander Hamilton which
were heavily relied on by lawyers at the
time of the Constitution's adoption
there were at the time of the
Constitution's adoption to great debates
that went on and it's very important to
understand the distinction between these
two great debates the first hard to
imagine today but the first was should
there be any power to impeach a
president at all and there were several
members of the founding generation and
of the framers of the Constitution who
said no who said no a president
shouldn't be allowed to be impeached the
second and the second is very very
important in our consideration today is
if a president is to be subject to
impeachment
what should the criteria be these are
very different issues and they are often
erroneously complained conflated let's
begin with the first debate during the
broad debate about whether a president
should be subject to impeachment
proponents of impeachment used vague and
open-ended terms such as unfit obnoxious
misconduct misbehavior negligence
malpractice perfidy treachery incapacity
peculation and maladministration
they worried that a president might
quote pervert his administration into a
scheme of speculation and oppression but
he might be corrupted by foreign
influence and yes this is important that
he might have great opportunities of
abusing his power
those were the concerns that led the
framers to decide that a president must
be subject to impeachment but not a
single one of the framers suggested that
these general fears justifying the need
for an impeachment and removal mechanism
should automatically be accepted as a
specific criterion for impeachment far
from it as governor Morris aptly put it
corruption and some other offenses or to
be impeachable but the cases ought to be
enumerated and defined the great fallacy
of many contemporary scholars and
pundits and with due respect members of
the House of Representatives is that
they fail to understand the critical
distinction between the bra